the Joe Rogan experience so like polar
bears at the base of the Bears right
they live in the coldest [ __ ] place
in those Caucasian Vikings are the
biggest dude in Iceland [ __ ]
yeah Icelandic just giant dudes if that
mountain from Game of Thrones
he's an Icelandic right yes yes that's
what that is that's gnarly that's gnarly
and he want to play basketball oh you
want to play basketball you seen him in
man yeah but a basket boat no look at no
I don't think he knows how to fight
there was a video of him sparring with
Conor McGregor huh Conor McGregor's
[ __ ] him up
what yeah yeah and Conor mean Conor's
not he's not weighing in so he's
probably weighing about 170 okay and
Game of Thrones guys easy three three
yes I would imagine he's in the 320 340
range and he's like a bodybuilder too so
he's like chasing you Connor and Connor
crack on the stomach uh it's kind of a
crazy video to watch five nine this
guy's what six seven he's taller than
$5.00 might be five that might be five
ten i'm 5-8 i won't disrespect you Conor
McGregor oh he's a beast yeah you get
the heart of an eight-foot person he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah I mean think I
fought Floyd Mayweather
with zero professional boxing fights
yeah just stop and think about that no
he's zero he took zero so he's legit so
here's Conor probably about a buck
seventy look at the size difference yeah
and they're like sparring and collars
moving around he's punched him in the
stomach I was trying to grab him but
Connor he let's let him grab but he's
not doing anything he's he's controlling
the guys trying to do something really
spoiling ground oh yeah yeah yeah guys
trying to grab him but he doesn't know
what he's doing and then he's like
high-fiving cars like no no no keep
going dude we're gonna keep going so now
he starts kicking him so it's kicking
him in the stomach leave it
see he's punch him in the stomach and
the big guy doesn't know what to do he's
trying to grab him but he can't as like
come on lat I can I keep going monster
yeah so Pro miner knows that this big
[ __ ] can't keep this up you
can't keep it out he's not he's not able
to keep up this pace so he's already
hurting I mean he's already tired me
come on yeah
going back and forth here oh no no first
of all you just got to a minute he's not
used to sparring right okay so
everything he's doing is like these big
movements and he's not breathing well so
he's all tense and tight so right now
once could take a deep breath
see all this is tension for him he's
very tense so now he's got a whole leg
but he doesn't know what to do yes
Conahan fights with them call Connor
just keep it moving
Connor in the stomach there you go and
then kind of like oh okay okay
so Connor is gonna keep going do that
now he's throwing kicks at him and I
guys didn't kick him in it can't be that
way
yeah it'll be too awkward no Connor I'll
trap him throw him to the ground or
something like that
he doesn't know how to kick but kind of
just gonna keep punched him in the
stomach but he eventually just gets
really really tired and he gives up but
it's kind of crazy to watch cuz Connor
essentially made him fight see look he
put God's knees just like that cop guy
yeah that was elves that was the big the
victim with the cop hey guys knees and
Connor didn't didn't allow him either
kasnian when the body look at this bro
he's gangster he's needing him and
punched him in the body she's I mean
there's a real kick so those were like
neat wow that guy is so much bigger than
that yeah he's a monster so yeah he's
not doing it even they training well
that's I mean he could it wasn't there I
mean he just doesn't know what to do
yeah but if he learned it what to do
Connor would never do that yeah that
guy's a he's a walking weapon like
liking Gallo Francis and gana who's
probably one of the biggest heavyweights
in the UFC
Connor would never do that with him yeah
the Train yeah he's a trained fighter
giant striker he'd [ __ ] him up both that
guy got it know what he's doing no the
mountain though yeah he's a he was a
basketball player he want to play
basketball then he broke his uh his
ankle or leg or something and every like
healed properly and he just became a
bodybuilder and then they put him in
Game of Thrones well he's a world
Strongest Man right exactly yeah he wins
those world Strongest Man is he's not
just like a participant so yeah he's
yeah he's the champ right he's crazy
strong and this guy is like Magnus ver
Magnusson right like this like his
mentor Magnus is that his mentor yeah
Magnus ver Magnusson went by what a
great name perfect name Magnus ver
Magnusson I [ __ ] love
like a strongman competent magna [ __ ]
laude uh Magnus ver Magnusson
yeah there's remember we well those
shows used to be on like ABC Wide World
of Sports
Asian would be on TV you would be
watching The Strongest Man competition
they don't throw barrels over the
[ __ ] bars I mean they're carrying
yeah they're carrying trucks an 18-wheel
semis yeah yeah always ridiculous [ __ ]
remember like the guys like they would
they would lift and like they attack
like a a hemorrhage and it just so I can
go through the nose oh yeah deadlifts
yeah one of the guys Robert Oberst was
on my podcast recently he's uh he's one
of those strong strongest men
competitors they're so big they don't
even look like real people
are you so big they're so big he's
[ __ ] gigantic humans the human body
is incredible it is man areas what did
he took in his nose smelling salt isn't
that nuts they do smelling salts before
they left some did drink whiskey or
something yeah why smelling salts I you
know I wouldn't drink the whiskey like
that would make me to relax I probably
[ __ ] myself or sometimes it just signs
of this [ __ ] yeah that's what he's
for 25 to 3 on the plate how much weight
is this didn't say it's a ton bro look
at the ours are oh God Jesus Christ look
at the [ __ ] bar Bendis good enough we
get it shot with the smelling salts are
so strange
Yeah right oh but NFL players do the
tool asylums if he did that right before
you were on stage right maybe we missing
out I think for you make sure you do
that should just [ __ ] Hitler Mussolini
just I just go up then just ramp for
five shot him did you see Rogen seven
hours oh my god Oh smelling all
brilliant what is his nose was bleeding
smell like took the best angles no I've
never asked if it was strong
and just yeah it pops your brain like
yeah now you've got [ __ ] damn yeah
you become like Dane Cook on said you'd
be like so physical no one's that fair
I don't no one's smelling salts physics
no it's a girl we should make Jeremiah
Watkins do it
oh my conceive Watkins on smelling salt
yeah he would be the first guy to be
have like what kind of physical comedies
yeah I like smelling salts physical the
most physical level not cocaine yeah
that Kinnison [ __ ] you talking about
smelling salt well who's like you'd be
like Dane Cook is one of the most
physical like Jim Carrey was very
visible right Robin Williams yeah but
Jim Carrey would like fall down and
[ __ ] do pratfalls and bro he's an
acrobat yeah he can move weird to hear
like a real flexibility to the way he
moves
yeah and we're in like Ace Ventura pet
detective I mean he but that was on
display right yeah I mean that was part
of his whole thing is how wacky he moves
you know smell a thousand places right
but then you'd have smelling salts
physical next-level [ __ ] just like those
kids in the day they couldn't do the BMX
flip three times well they can't right
yeah yeah that's the same thing with
smelling solid I gotta see this later
buddy try this I said ammonia is it yeah
just a releases ammonia when you break
the thing or when I open the cap or
whatever you don't try that's nothing
deine [ __ ] that's Windex used to make it
from deer antlers and hooves what yeah
uh called spirit of Hartshorn folks this
has been the most educational experience
ever of this podcast I would say with
both real and false information